[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde
et merci pour votre accueil avant même
de commencer je voulais vous dire à quel
point tu ai dit que c'était pour moi une
source d'inspiration depuis de
nombreuses années c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle je suis extrêmement
heureux de pouvoir partager ce moment de
convivialité convivialité et d'échangés
oui là je suis extrêmement heureux alors
je sais que ça ne se voit pas vraiment
mais vous devez me croire sur parole
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est à
dire la grande majorité d'entre vous je
m'appelle romain mais j'ai 32 ans et je
suis magicien je pratique la magie
depuis maintenant plus d'une dizaine
d'années et ma rencontre avec la magie
s'est fait alors que j'avais 19 ans
j'étais sauveteur en mer sur la côte
girondine et durant un entraînement j'ai
eu un accident très grave qui mobilisera
entrer dans une longue période de
convalescence d'opérations et de
rééducation durant cette période mes
parents eurent la bonne idée de me faire
rencontrer un magicien afin de me
changer les idées
je pense que je peux vous dire que c'est
certainement un des plus beaux jours de
ma vie car j'ai tout de suite compris
que la magie allait faire partie de mon
quotidien est certainement de toute ma
vie
enfin je l'espère alors pour mieux
comprendre le thème de la magie il faut
savoir qu'il existe de nombreuses
spécialités ou disciplines telles que la
grande illusion que vous avez
certainement déjà vu avec david
copperfield également le quick change
avec arturo brachetti et bien d'autres
en ce qui me concerne je pratique
exclusivement l'art du closet
alors je sais pas si vous savez de quoi
il s'agit mais le close up est un art de
la magie qui consiste à réaliser des
effets le plus proche possible des gens
alors pour certains vous êtes
relativement proche d'autres un petit
peu moins fait pourquoi je n'ai pas
vraiment décidé aujourd'hui de vous
faire du close up
j'aurais pu vous faire quelque chose
avec des petites particules par exemple
comme ça mais comme vous êtes un petit
peu loin
vous auriez eu du mal à voir
éventuellement la pièce j'aurais pu
également faire des tours des pièces
mais je suis patient vous aurez bien vu
grand chose
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de me
concentrer sur le thème qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui
mais qu'est ce que tu crois alors il
faut savoir que dans ma pratique de la
magie
j'ai pour habitude d'utiliser une
méthode particulière qui est la
suggestion et c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui
j'ai décidé de vous parler de la
suggestion au service de l' influence
pour mieux comprendre de quoi il s'agit
il est important de savoir que la
suggestion est en réalité basé sur des
idées des pensées ou même des images
ainsi la suggestion agit quotidiennement
sur les échanges qu'on peut la compo
avoir avec les individus toute
information est en réalité une
suggestion
c'est à dire une source d' influence ou
d'inspiration
la suggestion désigne avant tout une
influence d'une idée sur le comportement
mais à l inverse de ce que l'on peut
croire
il est important de savoir que la
suggestion n'était en aucun cas une
imposition ou une obligation
en réalité comme historiquement la
suggestion était mis en corrélation avec
l'hypnose de nombreuses personnes ont
fait un petit amalgames sur le sujet en
fait il est impossible d'imposer quelque
chose à quelqu'un contre sa volonté et
même en état d'hypnose
on peut simplement lui suggérer des
idées pour kilea qui les réalisent sans
s'en rendre compte
d'accord en réalité de par notre nature
humaine et la nature de nos pensées nous
utilisons la suggestion quotidiennement
par exemple un conseiller
la suggérer présenter ou influencer ses
idées sinon comment pourrait-il vous
conseiller un présentateur va va
suggérer présenter et influencer ses
idées sinon comment pourrait-il vous
conseiller ou présenter ses idées même
les idées parental baigne dans un dans
un monde de suggestions c'est à dire des
changes d'influx ans consciente ou
inconsciente
nous on essaye d'écorner du cno enfants
de leur faire passer nos idées
grâce à la suggestion nous vivons
littéralement dans un monde de
suggestions c'est à dire des changes de
d'influencés diverses et variées pour
tout vous dire durant cette présentation
j'ai décidé d'essayer de vous influencer
alors je sais que de vous avertir à
l'avancé va peut-être vous permettre de
vous préparer éventuellement même de
combattre cette influence ou cette
suggestion est ce à quoi j'aurai une
seule chose à vous dire
sachez qu'il ne s'agit en aucun cas d'un
concours il n'y aura ni gagnant ni
perdant à l'issue de cette
représentation
mais simplement nous pourrons
éventuellement tirer des conclusions sur
la force de la suggestion dans un
instant je vais montrer des cartes au
tableau et je vais vous demander de
faire un choix parmi ces cartes
je vous demandais de faire un choix
parmi ces cartes
alors évidemment ce soit doit se faire
de manière plutôt rapide car vous
n'allez pas avoir beaucoup de temps pour
pour choisir et avant de faire ça
j'aimerais juste à bord d un petit fuji
le sujet des cartes à jouer alors il
faut savoir que les cartes à jouer sont
assez fascinant car il existe tout un
tas de correspondance entre un jeu de
cartes et notre univers
et pour ne pas aborder tous les sujets
qu'ils existent on va se concentrer sur
les correspondances qu'il existe entre
un jeu de cartes et notre calendrier
alors si on prend un jeu de cartes
traditionnelles il contient 50 de cartes
par exemple plus le joker et 52 cartes
ça correspond aux 52 semaines dans une
année on a quatre signes dans un jeu de
cartes qui sont le pic le coeur le trait
fait le carreau qui correspondent aux
saisons dans une année on a également
deux couleurs le rouge et le noir qui
peuvent correspondre au jour et à la
nuit on a trois figures par signe qu'on
avale et d'amour one x le nombre de
signes ça fait 4 x 3 qui donne 12 et 12
c'est le nombre de mois dans une année
où également le nombre de cycles
solaires qui de cycle lunaire qu'il
existe dans une année si on se réfère à
l'astrologie
pour finir si l'on additionne l'ensemble
des valeurs d'un jeu de cartes avec la
ce pour un le valais pour 11 la dame
pour 12 et le roi pour 13 on tombe sur
364 je vous inviterai à vérifier parce
que c'est un fait relativement
intéressant et si on ajoute les joker
valant pour un bon évidemment ses pairs
donc il fallait deux d'entre eux mais
s'ils se faire juge si on ajoute les
cartes pour un on tombe sur 365 soit le
nombre de jours que contient une année
calendaire
d'accord tout ces événements sont
relativement intéressant parce que il
est indéniable que les études qu'on fait
les cons fait les européens et notamment
les français sur les jeux de cartes ont
permis cette oreille et cette magnifique
mystification qu'il existe autour autour
des jeux
encore aujourd'hui de l'utilisation des
autres cartes se fait de différentes
manières par exemple on peut jouer entre
amis ou entre en famille on peut
utiliser un jeu de cartes pour amuser la
galerie faire des tours de magie
par exemple on peut également escroqué
ses ennemis en jouant au bonneteau et on
peut évidemment lire dans l'avenir
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
d'ici un petit instant je vais retourner
les cartes je vous demandait de choisir
une carte
et pour être bien sûr que tout le monde
ne s'est pas endormi pendant ces
quelques minutes je vais vous demander
si vous voulez bien de tous levé la main
tous levé la main alors il n'a pas pour
longtemps je continue juste quelques
secondes
alors pour cette expérience je vais
évidemment vous pouvez garder la main
levée s'il vous plaît vous donnez avait
pour cette expérience je vais avoir
besoin de quelques volontaires
maintenant c'est gentil merci merci
merci merci vous pouvez tous vous levez
vous pouvez tous vous lever si vous
voulez bien participer à l'expérience
évidemment si vous pouvez vous lever je
vous demanderais de tous vous lever
merci beaucoup
très bien alors ça va aller relativement
vite je vous demande de faire ce choix
de manière intuitive si on peut dire de
manière honnête surtout je vous
demanderai une fois que vous avez fait
ce choix de ne plus changer d'avis ou
d'accord et surtout de ne pas influencer
votre voisinage
par exemple en leur donnant
l'information de la carte que vous avez
choisi c'est très important et ça durant
toute la durée de notre petite
conférence
ok vous êtes prêts
tout le monde a une carte en tête si une
personne dans la salle n'a pas de carton
tête ou plusieurs ce n'est pas grave je
demanderai juste de vous asseoir parce
que malheureusement vous pourrez pas
suivre le reste de l'expérience mais je
pense que vous avez été attentif
je suis plutôt rassuré maintenant vous
avez tous une carte en tête j'ai enlevé
sur la prochaine slide une seule carte
alors il serait impossible évidemment
que tout le monde ait choisi la même
carte mais il serait intéressant qu'une
bonne majorité ait choisi la carte que
j'ai enlevé alors vous demandera
évidemment d'être tout à fait honnête et
si la carte que vous avez choisie n'est
plus présente sur le prochain slide je
vous demanderais 12 à soir d'accord on
va voir ça vous êtes prêts
parfait ça bien non c'est bien c'est
bien c'est possible vous inquiétez pas
c'est tout à fait possible c'est
intéressant mais c'est possible c'est
intéressant de voir qu'avec une simple
expérience et en quelques minutes on a
réussi à réunir plus de 80 % de
l'audience avec un effet de suggestions
une influence mais ça va nous permettre
d'aller un petit peu plus loin parce que
dans les personnes qui restent ici dans
la salle nécessairement il y a quatre
groupes de personnes il ya des personnes
qui ont choisi le roi de pique
les personnes qui ont choisi le de 13
des personnes qui ont choisi de mettre
carreaux et des personnes qui ont choisi
la dame de trèfle
je vais vous demander de bien penser à
la carte vous avez choisi et on va
tenter une deuxième expérience qui se
veut beaucoup plus complexe parce que
cette fois ci vous allez avoir un champ
des possibles quasiment illimité c'est à
dire que vous allez pouvoir faire un
choix sur quelque chose qui ne sera pas
simplement cinq cartes
ok alors vous allez vite comprendre
merci de bien d'écouter les consignes
parce que c'est plus complexe où tout à
l'heure donc pour toutes les personnes
qui ont choisi le roi de pique
je vais vous demander de penser à une
ville ça peut être n'importe quelle
ville une ville de france d'europe du
monde ça peut être une ville
relativement connu simplement merci de
faire en sorte que la ville soit connue
de la majorité des personnes dans la
salle
je donne un exemple paris ou bordeaux
seraient des bons exemples
cependant un rounding et à gollum ne
seraient pas des bons exemples alors
merci de penser à une destination que je
ne viens pas de citer et gardez bien là
en tête avec la carte que vous avez
choisi donc roi de pique plus la
destination pour le deuxième groupe de
joueurs qui sont du coup le 2 2 trèfles
je vais vous demander de penser à deux
formes géométriques simples tout en
sachant qu'avec mes talents artistiques
1 une étoile ou un coeur serait des
formes complexes et un carré ou un
rectangle seraient des formes réalisable
d'accord merci de ne pas penser à ce que
je viens de citer
mais de penser à deux formes
géométriques simples c'est bon tout le
monde a pour les personnes qui ont
choisi le trèfle très bien enfin on a un
troisième groupe de joueurs qui ont
choisi le valet de carreau je vais
demander de penser à une couleur ça peut
être n'importe quelle couleur ça peut
être une couleur primaire une couleur un
petit peu plus complexe simplement je
sais c'est un petit peu long des deux
boom fallait pas choisir cette voie là
non simplement merci de ne pas penser à
la couleur rouge et vous pouvez penser à
ce que vous voulez on évite le marteau
rouge
du coup ne pensez pas à la couleur rouge
d'accord pour les personnes qui ont
choisi la dame de trèfle
je vais vous demander de penser à deux
prénoms ça peut être deux prénom de
fille de prénoms de garçons
ça peut être un prénom de fille ou de
garçon des prénoms mixtes peu importe
simplement essayé de penser à des
prénoms qui soit relativement connue
pour que la majorité des personnes dans
la salle
puissent les connaître par exemple marie
nicolau mohammed seraient des bons
exemples
j'ai pas forcément de contre exemple
mais merci de penser à un prénom deux
prénoms comme je vous ai dit est de bien
garder en tête parfait si on résume on a
quatre groupes de joueurs avec deux
pensées en tête la carte plus la pensée
que je vous ai donné
donc d'ici un petit instant je vais
révéler ce que j'ai essayé de vous
suggérer depuis le début de vous
influencer à savoir que vous êtes encore
relativement nombreux donc cette fois ci
je vous demanderais pour tout perdre
toutes les personnes à qui j'ai demandé
de penser à deux éléments dont par
exemple les deux forment les deux
prénoms de considérer l'expérience comme
réussite si je ne trouve qu'un seul des
deux éléments
ça paraît clair très bien ce que j'ai
essayé de vous suggérer
si vous avez pensé à la ville sydney à
la forme géométrique triangle ou cercles
à la couleur jaune et aux prénoms arthur
ou robin je vous demanderai de vous
asseoir parfait on n'ira pas plus loin
dans l'expérience mais finalement du
coup vous pouvez vous asseoir
finalement ce qui est intéressant on a
on a une - un petit peu moins d'une
dizaine de personnes ce qui représente
finalement 2 3% à l'audience on a réussi
avec deux expériences relativement
simple de réunir plus de 98 % de
l'audience
alors je sais qu'il est certainement
trop tard pour croire en notre bon vieux
père noël mais sachez qu'une n'est
jamais trop tard pour croire en la magie
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]